Once upon a time, Chinese economic performance
wasn't global news.
Those days are long gone.
The country's growth rate now acts as an indicator
for the health of the entire world's economy.
No wonder then that this announcement was
so hotly anticipated:
According to preliminary estimates, the total
value of China's GDP was 90.03 trillion yuan,
a 6.6-percent year-on-year increase as calculated
by comparable price.
That outstripped the anticipated goal of around
6.5 percent.
6.6 percent.
It may not sound too shabby.
But take a look at this:
A decade ago, Chinese economic growth was
hovering around 10 percent.
In the years since then, it's slowed steadily
.. And what's worrying investors is that no
one knows when that decline is going to end.
The reasons for China's slowdown are manifold.
Domestic issues, like a slowing property market
are putting pressure on growth.
But even more worrying to the global markets
is the continuing trade dispute with the United
States.
The two countries are currently holding a
90-day trade truce which their leaders agreed
to after dining together at the G20 summit
in Argentina back in November.
Further trade talks are set to take place
at the end of January.
But after months of volatility, the prospect
of a resolution is far from certain.
A further escalation could have a dramatic
impact on the Chinese economy - and by extension
the rest of the world too.